hey guys this is dense the founder thing
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of boardwalk empire season
4 episode 11 the second to last episode
of the season even of grace not gonna
butcher the French it's in the French
from not gonna do the French
pronunciation but translates havener
grace location does in Maryland okay so
it's interesting cuz I actually thought
like this episode would be more
action-packed I thought wearing it kind
of like last season a two-parter yeah
thing but really this is slow things
down yeah this was kind of like another
set up for the final episode so let's
start off with with chalky you know so
yeah Chalky's in full on revenge
thinking cuz he thinks that Nucky sold
him out right when Nucky actually didn't
but it just looks that way but then you
know then he gets to meet his you know
friend this longtime mentor Oscar for
inviting a Lewis Gossett jr. which is
awesome to see him and doing some stuff
and you know starts slowing down a
little bit you know looking and thinking
of life think about his new lady that he
has like maybe I might want to you know
do something you know run away or you
know we're off into the sunset with this
girl and not not not not secretly yeah
because Oscar tell him look at the end
of the day like he had a great lines
like everyone runs out of Road great i
was basically saying look you you know
you're gonna accomplish by going yeah
you're a lose you'll die something bad
will happen eventually so you might as
well now his thing was not to run off
with a girl cuz he don't like her i want
to take over his action with early as
this were like build it up where he was
at right especially cuz he was you know
well he's about done yeah yeah but
obviously that wasn't gonna happen what
are you like know the story wasn't gonna
end they didn't do this whole season
right so that chalky and his woman can
go away together no i'm happily ever
that's not what why we watch this whole
season of boardwalk and now with oscar
dad you can see the fire in his eyes
he's going to take those those guys that
are in that crew and go up and do some
more and he doesn't know where the girl
and the girl might have gone back to dr.
Narcisse yeah and you know maybe told
him that way right is that I don't know
we work over the guy that city had to go
into town or something it never came
back out yeah so yeah I'm sure we'll see
that
the conclusion that is is chalky gonna
kill dr. Narcisse all right I mean it's
not he's not gonna kill Nucky but no
somehow hopefully they work it out you
know cuz I cuz Nucky did wasn't trying
to kill him no rocky it was actin a
Kentucky was actually loyal to right he
just couldn't he just didn't get that
time yeah yeah so and then we have well
speaking of Nucky then we have the whole
storyline with Nucky and Eli yeah i mean
with Eli it's it's tough I just I just
think like because he betrayed his
brother already I'm surprised he's doing
it again why doesn't he open up to his
brother and see if his brother can help
him out yeah situation lucky always
finds a way out I mean even kind of
stuck up for Nucky when he was talking
to the aging a little bit there in the
beginning I mean he was saying like a
look at my brother you know he's he's
smart he knows what he's doing I don't
get away yeah I don't get why he doesn't
try to ask him for help it doesn't make
any sense yeah and he like kind of
flipped out on his wife yeah one point
cuz he saw enough you look like mmm
interesting you wonder if lucky knows I
mean at the end was talking to Patricia
Arquette you kind of think like he might
know he's like I got his one out like he
seems like it's just tired of all this
all the scheming and who's doing what
can he who can he trust who can he trust
Nick he says he's tired of it yeah I
think he has suspicions of his brother
cuz he did that whole thing at the N
word he wanted to test yeah his kind of
temper are in his reaction so he brought
up this thing that used to irk him along
right yeah and there was like no
reaction ever know right and he's like
well why is this why is he getting so
upset over this supposed my insurance
agent right now so he I think he knows
something's up and the whole babyface
thing yeah right exactly because the
Tolliver has a baby face and then I
guess not too many people have that and
like yeah I guess so he's putting the
dots together yeah so I don't know I
don't know what's gonna end up happening
to you hi I don't know I mean I like Eli
I like when he came back and he was
loyal to his brother again I want to see
more that I don't want him I don't want
I mean I'm expecting a Fredo moment from
godfather to was like I knew it was you
you broke my heart you know one of those
I don't want to see that with them I
thought the relationship got stronger
after he got her prison but obviously i
don't know maybe with all the threats to
his son that court case coming up with
her son you know the whole murder thing
at college maybe he's just trying to
protect his family he thinks is the best
way to do it yeah Sun's up in up in the
mix right the thing about the the Sun is
kind of acting kind of cocky oh yeah
like that yeah he's like yeah toss the
cigarette always so cool like like yeah
you're the guy who's like scared to
death cuz you're about to go to prison
right how many years I also too I think
looking a more this episode one of the
weaker parts and it goes up so it was
the whole Jillian side it's not because
I just I'm not that it shouldn't
Julian's character now Lula's the whole
setup was the Pinkertons yeah you know
and then highly another guy's name from
sopranos you played uncle junior yes
uncle Jun you know it's just I don't I
don't care about Jillian's fate so the
fact that she's goes to prison like well
yeah she's kind of distant horrible
things like probably should go to prison
way I don't want that bad for her uh
yeah the hard life she's it a hard life
I'm kind of in between in terms of
feeling I do kind of feel bad for just
cuz her life kind of has sucked for
writing she was like Raven she was like
12 or however old she was had a Jimi and
yeah she just got had a spirit life and
in at the moment where she thinks she's
found clarity right down peace big way
yeah she thinks okay i can let go of my
grandson he'll live a good life with
herro and his new wife and i can just
run away with this guy i love and live
happily ever after and leave all the bad
stuff that she's gone through in her
life right behind her and it gets ripped
right out yeah because the whole time
and we knew there was some sort of
ulterior motive he had we just write
what it was I mean I thought something
was gonna happen in the garage I mean
something did happen he didn't kill a
man but I thought that like he was like
the setup something was gonna happen
like where she was gonna get in trouble
but yeah I mean apparently he just set
her up leave that she had killed someone
right and so should they could get that
confession out of her yeah I mean it was
you know as well played it just as
Pinkertons at the pig
got to we had to go to the Federal
Bureau is almost like to so many sides
over here I I guess I mean I know we're
gonna get in the finale but another
fellow I thinks gonna be probably an
hour along i want my wanted some new
york i want some chicago this F is in
chicago i want to see less julianne
moore yeah hopefully we'll see you in
the finale well hopefully now Jillian
story's done yeah like right that should
be I mean I thought it would have been
done last season like the heroin
overdose I think it should be done that
we shouldn't even see any more yeah we
need to see her you know where the you
know harrows at where the the grandsons
and we know her fate like that's it we
don't need to see her anymore so
hopefully maybe that was just kind of
way to us we don't forget another season
so hopefully this is a way to kind of
usher her away and I don't know say
maybe she'll kill herself in prison I
like Gretchen whoa I don't that bad no
she's right on the show Angela I think
her character just outlived her
usefulness right I think this season was
not very necessary for her care exactly
all right so I'm looking forward to the
final episode ever we you know we'll get
to see some more of the actual war going
on now Nucky's somehow he's doing
something right he's not gonna you know
give up that easily ya know and those do
what chalky does when he knows gonna be
conversational chalking lucky gonna be
curiously how Nucky talks as whether
this wonder convinces Chucky that hey
look I am on your side with all these
people trying to attend in attack attack
and chalky all the stuff they built
together Narcisse you know I mean they
gotta do something about it and then why
don't know what kind of Capone and Van
Alden you know I mean all those guys
Lucky Luciano Meyer Rothstein Rothstein
don't forget about um mrs. Schroeder you
know as I call her you know she's got
her thing going with Rothstein right now
they got their whole little deal going
on the side so know what that's going to
me there's a lot of stuff to wrap up
alright guys so let us know what you
thought you post your comments below on
the website think Eric amor on our
YouTube channel think you're a pro make
sure you subscribe to that does wanna go
chat with Dennis and I on Twitter you
know talk to us about the show broke
Empire would you know what are you
liking what are you expecting to happen
in the finale you can find both of us at
think hero personally i'm at griffin de
and we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure to like that page and
you know share our video turn it out and
get other people to check it out all
right thanks